so how long have you been in japan now
you moved this will be my
third year only three yeah i know it
feels like longer
it feels like you were here before i
moved no did you ever live in japan
before or just
um i'm i was here until i i was born
here and then i was here until i was
three and then
i would come back every summer and
winter
um and i'd go to japanese school during
that time
i never had summers off it's really
scary wait so you had a holiday where
you'd go on holiday and go to school on
holiday yes
it was it's messy that's japan
yeah that is japanese literally son
you're gonna love this i've booked you
for another six weeks of school you're
gonna love it yeah so in the end i would
get like maybe two weeks of summer
vacation
but like winter there's no school so
when you were watching like phineas and
ferb right and like
talking about all these days of vacation
that's a [ __ ] lie
it was heartbreaking because like i'd
watch all these other cartoons that were
like oh summer vacation
three months and i'm like what is that
what is that i was like who has time to
camp when i have to finish my math
homework i was like wait i have this
kanji test like i have four conju tests
coming
up like what what's a break so how long
did you do that for until what age
until middle school um until end of
middle school so i graduated middle
school and then
14 13 uh 13 yeah and then when
it came when high school came around um
my
parents and i got together and they were
like do you want to go for a japanese
university or an american university
like where do you want to like end up
and at the time i was like america
like there's this boy i have a crush on
like
so also like i only knew of japan during
the summer and winter so i was very
conscious that like i don't know how to
live in japan
yeah well yeah because you experienced
the two extremes right yeah
and i was like this isn't fun like well
it was it was
but um i was very aware that i i don't
know how to live
in japan so and also my english was way
more superior than my japanese even
after all that schooling
maybe i'm just dumb but uh yeah so i
decided i wanted to go to an american
university so that allowed me to drop
all of my japanese stuff because you
know in america like you study for the
sats
so so yeah that's what happened and then
20.
years later i moved back to japan
full circle yeah um i never ever in my
life thought i would want to be living
in japan
was that how you imagined it to be hmm
well you know it sucks because
the first year i moved to so i moved
like towards the end of 2018
2018 into 20 end of 2019 was phenomenal
it's exactly how i envisioned it
yeah work was flowing in the way i
needed it to and the way it made sense
i was going back and forth between the
us and japan like doing hosting gigs
here
here and there so the whole everything
like kind of tied together in harmony
and then you know i keep bringing it up
like i can't help it covet hit
yeah and now everything is so dislodged
and again like i said before i'm just
trying to stay relevant so that i can
have that back i can have that rhythm
and harmony back
and so now it feels more like a trying
to stay relevant
catch up game and it's just it's a
little bit
weird but i'm sure it's weird for
everybody like it was a mess it's been a
message
i feel like i've only had a collective
like
experience of moving here for about like
four months because yes
that's the the amount of time i've
stayed here before covered here so
i don't really feel like my journey in
japan has like started i feel really bad
for you guys honestly because it's like
yeah again as you said like you guys
have been for almost two years now
mm-hmm
but it just feels like i feel like
you've barely gotten to experience
what it's like right i think i i think
i'm very lucky that i ended up in the
one country where it wasn't
affected too heavily obviously obviously
you know it was kind of bad here but you
know we were able to keep doing this
podcast we wanted to like go
outside like it was like you know
whereas in the uk it was like
no one is allowed to leave your house
yeah at all and they were really strict
about it right so i was like pretty glad
i feel like i kind of escaped but then
also on the other hand it's like i feel
super isolated here
yeah like yeah you know it doesn't help
with the time zones it's completely
different so you barely get to talk to
people on other time zones you know so
it's kind of uh i think this is the
first ever time i've ever like felt
homesick and i don't normally feel like
home homesick but it was just more like
man just you know not being able to see
my family and my friends that's that's
different from like
you know knowing that i can see them
whenever i like
i mean i i feel that and you know this
is technically my home like
like i haven't been able to see my
family here for like over a year now
really yeah just because we well just
because like we agreed as a family
totally not see each other until covert
was over because like
last thing i want to do is give my
cousin covert of course
that would be [ __ ] so i'm curious was
there any like big reason or is like a
turning point that made you think like
we're moving to japan
um well the timing factor is that i was
just
really sick of la but also um
during the year that i decided to move
here i was going
back and forth to japan a lot and it
made me
miss every time i came back my wanting
to leave
miss japan yeah it would just get like
deeper and and intense and then
um you know i never grew up with my
family
at all it was always like my parents are
divorced and my mom raised me alone in
a foreign country it seems weird saying
america is my foreign country but it is
and like i was never a citizen i was an
immigrant i'm a green card holder in
america i'm a japanese oh really oh wow
yeah i'm like a hard japanese nationals
okay until i
married my american husband i was never
actually an asian american
so all right in a way i was like i don't
know if i belong here like i know i
i fake it and maybe that's like just
kind of like works its way into my
actual personality but
i'm like i like my japanese soul wants
to be with my family
and um my cousin had her first
baby and i was watching her grow up from
la and it like kind of broke my heart
because i'm like
the new generation has started right
you know like my second cousins are my
one of them just graduated
college and i didn't get to watch her
grow up when i used to babysit her when
she was a baby and
in the summers right in between kanji
tests um
and i don't know like as i aged i really
felt like
i would be so angry at myself if i
didn't take this
opportunity right now to at least
experience living in japan
as a japanese person and being around my
family and then um it actually did
like the timing was insane because kova
did happen but then
unfortunately my grandfather was like
diagnosed with cancer but i was there
for him
and that's all i wanted like it would
have killed me it would have killed me
if i couldn't be here for them you know
yeah and in a way like first of all like
he was
old as [ __ ] like it's okay like he lived
last night and he smoked like a pack of
cigarettes
it's fine but like the fact that i
got to be there and i don't have to feel
like there was this big hole
that i you know in my life again because
i lost my grandparents on my dad's side
when i was younger and i was
in college and i couldn't get out of
college i couldn't take time off to go
see them so that was like always such a
huge stain
in my life and yeah i was like this
makes so much sense
so i i feel really bad now because i
remember like as a kid
right you'd go to your you go to some
family reunion
and your parents well my parents would
introduce me to like this uncle or
something
and they'd be like oh i remember when
you were just little baby i held you i
helped raise you up and
i was just like thanos i don't even know
who you are
now like now that i've had like cousins
who you know i've had kids and i've you
know
held them and seen them grow up as well
i know i'm going to say exactly the same
thing i don't know i'm going to be that
uncle now and i know the kid is just
going to look at me the same way
you're going to be una reversed